[Musique]
euh
donc
[Musique] [Musique
]
étrangère
[Musique]
actuellement je pense qu'il y aurait euh
et il y a effectivement
un débat sur le déplacement des vestiges archéologiques
et leur décontextualisation euh et donc l'
un est l'argument de la
décontextualisation
et puis  l'autre, l'argument est en faveur
de la sécurité des artefacts
et je dois dire que le granit va
probablement s'en sortir très bien,
mais les sphinx sont faits de
grès
et sont une pierre plus sensible,
d'autant plus
que le climat change et qu'il
pleut plus fréquemment que  Le Caire
et il y a beaucoup de trafic et de
pollution, donc je pense que
ce n'est pas la meilleure pratique
en matière d'antiquités en ce qui concerne
[la musique] à
Tahrir en 2011, où les gens non seulement
s'asseyaient ensemble mais conversaient
entre eux, ils
avaient des réunions, ils avaient
des discussions significatives, ils  J'ai aussi dansé,
chanté et mis des pancartes et
c'est quelque chose d'aussi simple que
cela est profondément
subversif en ce qui
concerne l'État égyptien et je pense que ce que
nous voyons maintenant
est une décision concertée, délibérée et très
consciente.  de la part de
l'État,
pour empêcher que cela ne se reproduise,
c'est une tentative délibérée de
dire que l'État que ce qui s'est passé en
2011 était une erreur,
nous pouvons facilement en effacer toute trace de la
mémoire publique et nous transformons la
place en quelque chose  sinon
[Musique]
toi